Rison journalist robbie suave has been
writing about culture free speech due
process and moral outrage on campus
since joining the magazine in 2014 that
year he was one of the first reporters
to questioning the veracity of a Rolling
Stone article that accused several
fraternity brothers of a horrific gang
rape at the University of Virginia a
story the magazine later retracted
because of insufficient evidence earlier
this year when a clip of Magha
hat-wearing high school students
appearing to intimidate a Native
American man went viral Soave was one of
the first journalists to carefully
scrutinize the raw video discovering
that the interaction was more
complicated than the outraged mob that
claimed major media organizations later
looped back to acknowledge that they had
erred in their reporting I don't blame
the kids so many people admitted they
made snap judgments before these other
facts came in the 30 year old suave has
just published his first book panic
attack young radicals in the age of
Trump which examines the ascendancy of
what he calls the intersectional left
and the identitarian rights among young
political activists
I talked with suave about his experience
reporting and writing the book today's
political climate on campus and why he
thinks college activists emphasis on
identity is misplaced so Robert what is
panic attack about panic attack is about
problems that I've noticed on college
campuses for the last couple years
threats to free speech due process and
other values of classical liberals that
are often coming from the left from
students who would describe themselves
as progressives even though progressives
would have supported many of these
things like free speech and due process
but now the students who call themselves
progressive are shutting down speakers
who they disagree with or who make
someone on campus feel uncomfortable are
calling for policies that have made it
harder for people accused of misconduct
to get a fair trial have done things
that threaten certain liberal principles
on campus and obviously they would like
to export these practices too not just
to other
emphases but also to the country at
large to the firm to social media
companies which are now making decisions
like this for what kind of content is
okay so it's interviews with student
activists people who march in the street
in d c-- berkeley other places who want
social change and interviews with them
about why they like these tactics and
where their ideas come from and these
activists that you're examining are
mostly on what you call the
intersectional left although there's
also an examination of the identitarian
right near the end of the book as a
libertarian what is your interest in
exploring these ideologies sure i mean i
was just so interested by over the last
few years the changes I saw taking place
you know it used to be that someone
who's very progressive has like an ACLU
approach to free speech that you know
even if it's a crazy hateful person
shouting something you know during
military servicemembers funeral like
that's the Westboro Baptist Supreme
Court case that we were gonna defend
their right to do so and that was such
an ironclad progressive value but we
have seen increasingly over the last
couple years
things like charles murray coming to
speak at a number of universities and
he's being shouted down by not all
students not most students but a small
number of activists who think that him
being allowed to speak it's not just
that they disagree with him but it's
that his words cause emotional harm to
certain people on campus and that is a
form of violence and thus it's not only
justified but necessary to protect
people from the harm that his words
caused that was such a kind of new thing
i mean shutting down speakers is not new
but doing it for an explicit sort of
safety ism it was a trend that I saw
developing so I became very interested
in talking to the students about why
they liked that strategy or think that
strategy is so important a lot of the
policies that we've seen play out on
college campuses things like trigger
warnings or microaggression databases
safe spaces all the stuff you hear about
are couched in that language of safety
and words as violence or causing
physical harm I mean where does
that idea come from were you able to
discover like where the what the genesis
of that was so first it's important to
realize that this immense bureaucracy
has grown on campuses over the last
couple dozen years to now adjudicate
these claims to now provide monitoring
and reporting services there's
administrators who are paid very
handsomely there's tons of them they've
their salaries and ranks have increased
in the ways the faculties have not again
over the last thirty years or so so now
there's this this bureaucracy to treat
these concerns very seriously they've
also learned these concerns I think a
little bit from a philosophy that I
described in the book is
intersectionality which is something
that came about in the 1980s out of a
sociology this idea that there are
different kinds of oppression there's
racism there's sexism anti-gay animus on
and on and on but they're related but
they're separate and they stack and the
more and you have to be against all of
them it's not enough to just fight one
of these things and that's become more
influential for progressives so now on
campus where again we're talking about
relatively privileged people there's
actually campus in the literal physical
safety sense is safe than many other
places in fact even the sexual assault
problem women of the same age as
students who are not actually on
campuses are in greater danger of sexual
assault than female students so they're
the problems are not necessarily I think
as large as many make them out to be but
you have but these grievances are there
and they have a bureaucracy that's
dealing with them and they have a
philosophy that all these things must be
confronted at once and no matter the big
things from like racism sexism - you
know what pronouns you're being
addressed with or do you have you know
things like of that nature and if you're
not fighting all of them you are not in
good standing in the progressive
community so that's driving a lot of
this yes we must oppose obviously
fascism and Trump but we also must
oppose whoever else comes to speak and
we will also fight even the ACLU if they
come here because they support free
speech rights which is what happened at
William and Mary uh within the last two
years they actually the progressives a
protest
did a speaker with the ACLU because they
rejected the idea that that free speech
is a value that's on their side well so
if intersectionality is the ideology it
you describe it as kind of stacking so
you might be a woman but also latina and
also gay and those three things add up
to a higher level of oppression the
logic does seem to make some sense I
mean these are all different
marginalized groups so it seems like
compounding that would create possibly
more problems more oppression for a
given individual so what's your critique
of intersectionality and where do you
think it actually gets things right
right so I think it's true as you just
said so I agree with it i urea Slee
these are sources of real oppression in
society and kimberlé crenshaw
who is the sociologist who came up with
it she was trying to say that you know
if you're you she wanted activists to
not just fight racism without fighting
sexism that was like her goal so I again
the theory is fine as a tactical sort of
framework for bringing about social
change I have some concerns about it and
how it's being applied in particularly
again it's all well and good to fight
sexism and racism but as we've added
again more and more and more grievances
I mean you know most Americans many
Americans you can get them to show up
maybe to a March to fight to the women's
March for instance because of trumps
appalling record on women because if
people are fired up against anti sexism
but the activists I talked to again the
far-left progressive activists they said
the women's March was no good they
deliberately avoided it because it
wasn't intersectional by that they meant
the people in charge of it were not
trans women of color right they were not
people who satisfied multiple
marginalized statuses so my point of
view is you're gonna require that every
sort of activist thing you do or every
attempt at social change
you know checks off all of these boxes
you're going to have a hard time doing
anything hmm
because you are you who you know
believe that all these boxes must be
checked off our few where you know all
of Americans some might hold you know
progressive views on race and sex issues
they may but maybe they're not forget or
they are for gay marriage but they you
know support Israel and the
israel-palestine conflict or so there's
all these kinds of different you know
people are different you can't have a
single issue coalition if you require
everyone to be to agree on every single
further more fringe thing a leftist
progressive wants and it's produced I
mean my book is a chronicle of
oftentimes hilarious infighting based on
these issues the the DSA the Democratic
socialists of America you know they they
put out sort of a plan for a
medicare-for-all type thing and that
drew criticism from their disability
working group because the disabilities
issue people said how dare you you know
come out with discharge without having
consulted us for the marginalized group
most affected by this we should have
been leading the charge only we have
authority to to lead this issue and
there was infighting which was kind of
ridiculous but that's where a militant
adherence to intersectionality gets you
and you see conservatives observing this
with a sort of Glee because it's the
left eating its own from their
perspective
I mean I'm it provides it provides
moments of amusement for libertarians as
well but I mean what is your attitude
towards seeing this all play out on the
Left I mean is it something that we
should just kind of sit back and and let
it happen or or what are your concerns
if any yeah I think I write this exactly
in the book that part of the reason I
I'm so interested in where the left's
going wrong is that occasionally I would
like them to succeed I criminal justice
issues are one thing I talk about in the
book I have a chapter on sort of the
black lives matter group which I think
and I think the effect that black lives
matter has had on the country and on
policy is still being written I think we
absolutely don't know for sure and now
and it's a big group and it's had
positive impacts in some places and
probably negative impacts other places
it and it's confusing because Trump is
in
self you know runs on this very
law-and-order anti criminal justice kind
of platform and then has one
conversation with Kim Kardashian and
Kanye West and is now suddenly
interested in sentencing reform but so
my concern about something like like the
the intersectional and the very identity
approached approach of a black lives
matter for instance you know they made
this about about the impact of these
issues on a specific racial group and I
worry that that made it less appealing
to a brought to to getting more
Americans on board with it you know if
I'm trying to get older conservatives on
board with criminal justice reform I'm
not gonna say like you're complicit in
racism if you don't agree with me I'm
gonna talk about how this just cost too
much money and even police say you can't
keep drugs out of jail for goodness sake
you know you're gonna talk about those
things
the intersectional approach is saying
that we have to talk about how this is
most the this is most horrible for this
group of people and so on and so forth
making it identity based because people
in the country hate identity politics I
think can turn people off
and so that's my concern suave says the
intersectional left has inadvertently
empowered its mirror image the alt-right
members of which clashed with protesters
in Charlottesville Virginia in 2017 at
that event one man ran over and killed a
protester with his car we're in a very
bad moment in our politics for the kind
of ideas that I like for classical
liberalism or individual libertarianism
on both sides I mean you know I'm
criticizing the left for kind of
abandoning some of these individual
liberty values that I hold in so much
esteem but of course the right has is
going in in the same but opposite
direction in is more tribal is more
populist is more nationalist I mean
there's a debate going on right now and
conservative pundit circles about
further retreating from sort of a
Liberty a slightly libertarian framework
into a more explicitly almost the ik
Radek direction and this is happening
you know everywhere this is happening in
Europe this is even further advanced in
Europe between a kind of far left
progressive socialist paradigm and a
very national
conservative paradigm if these two
extremes
you know they butt heads and then both
feel more justified in going more the
other direction I mean that's something
I talk about the the people who start on
the alt-right pathway are just making
fun of leftist to begin with or they're
making fun of you know leftist political
correctness overreach and then they're
saying horrible things just to trigger
people on the left and then they're
coming to actually believe these
horrible things and they're its
justifying their behavior and the same
thing happens the other way too so I am
criticizing from my perspective of I
would like to move both these groups
back to to having something of
appreciation for values that in
not-so-distant times they had more
interest in and yes so you do cover the
alt-right in the book or the
identitarian right what is the
relationship there that you see between
the intersectional left and the
identitarian right how are they feeding
off of each other yeah I wanted to
survey you know activists young activist
groups that have arisen in the Trump era
and the old right you know while a still
a small fringe group that I think maybe
had its high water market for in terms
of how many people and how much we were
talking about them with the
Charlottesville a few years ago and
hopefully that's the high-water mark for
them I think we would all be happier if
you never hear from them again but they
see themselves as a reaction to some
degree to the left as an explicit or a
co-opting of identity politics but for
white people I mean this is how Richard
Spencer described his movement when I
interviewed him for the book he said
yeah I mean he wants things like like a
welfare state but for white people he
says it's good to derive meaning from
your membership in a racial category
which again this is the exact sort of
opposite way I think meaning drives for
a meaning derives from you being an
individual and we all as individuals
have rights and it's not because you are
preordained into some racial group but
that's how this very fringe
right movement sees themselves and you
know and I do it's not fair I think to
blame obviously the the violence and the
bad things the right has done is not
somehow the left's fault is the fault of
the people who did it without any
question but these fringe groups do feed
on each other I mean they fight each
other online all the time you know they
they see their the I think people
adjacent to the alt-right and may be
interested to some degree and all right
ideas feel like man those people are
right look look this person you know who
isn't even alright they got kicked out
of campus or kicked off social media or
whatever they're being censored so then
they'll it looks the the kind of
conspiracy people seem right all along
to them when Provocateur milo
gianopolous accepted the invitation of a
conservative student group to speak at
UC Berkeley the campus erupted masked
protesters associated with the leftist
group and Tifa
threw Molotov cocktails at the police
and tossed barricades through windows to
protest gianopolous presence when riesen
visited campus a year later students
were ambivalent about what had occurred
the speech can be considered violence
inviting people like milo innopolis
creates an unsafe environment for the
people that he is speaking against what
do people say is the proper role of
political violence within these
movements yes certainly we've seen
violence in all these places Portland as
well has a lot of anti fire activity
going on certainly the activists we're
talking about and again this is not most
people there's not most students I'm
talking about a small number of
activists but they absolutely see
political violence as legitimate I mean
an tyfa is an organization with a
history going back to Europe in the
1930s the a the anti-fascists and they
mark Bray who's written a book called
the the anti fahan book about the
movement you know makes it explicit that
they are not a liberal movement they do
not believe in free speech they believe
in free speech if it's being harnessed
by an tyfa but we're not they're not
about defending the rights of people who
pollute achill motives they disagree
with so they're not saying I don't think
that we're all
always and automatically going to use
violence but there they are
there's nothing violence is not off the
table for them they are certainly
prepared to use violence in situations
and I mean I guess I saw this in the
research I was doing for the book I saw
some violence at Michigan when I saw
Charles Marie speak I saw some at
Berkeley when I visited I saw some at
Columbia when they had a controversial
far-right speaker come to speak and
again you know there's no one in there
there was a few people in the audience
this person was giving remarks in like a
basement it was fine there's nothing
very important happening there and you
go okay I don't know what the big deal
was and then you go outside and there's
just you know there are dozens and
dozens and dozens of people in masks and
black hoods and they're attacking each
other and they're talking about how we'd
like need to overthrow the entire
university and we'd like all of Western
capitalism or something and it's just
and it's like really fringe crazy stuff
it was just this one guy speaking you
could have ignored him and that would
have been probably you know he's
probably wants the protesters there to
feel like he had some effect do you just
ignore some of these people that would
be a better tactic than what an tyfa and
and even the other protesters do in so
many of these cases yeah I'm curious
about all of this as spectacle because
you talk about these incidents with
charles murray or we mentioned miley
annapolis and these get widespread media
coverage when they happen but some
people have argued that that's
disproportionate to the actual problem
that this is a pretty small group of
people and it's not really widespread on
college campuses for instance how
widespread a problem is it in your
estimation yeah i think there's a lot of
truth to that argument certainly these
things are over covered in a way that
may make them seem like they're getting
worse i mean you know if you wrote if
you're a student and you wrote some kind
of bad or easily mocked progressive
article for your student newspaper you
know when i was in college in the arts
you would have written it you might have
been mocked on campus but then it would
that would've been it it wouldn't
forgotten now you might have you know it
could be a cable news segment
about it so there's a there's a way that
these problems are may be blown up it's
very difficult to quantify qualify what
we're talking about I mean it's the case
that in it probably many probably most
universities especially we're talking in
community colleges as well smaller
schools that are not as much under the
national spotlight
they'll have speakers come and there's
no big deal you know this is a bigger
problem at better-known loftier
institutions your Harvard's your Yale's
Oberlin read prestigious liberal arts
colleges somewhat to some degree the UC
system so I never I'm always cautious
because I I don't I don't want to
overstate the problem I don't want to
scare people that's the opposite of what
I'm trying to do and again most students
are not like this and I don't even think
the number of students who do these
kinds of things has increased I just
think it's this it's so it's still the
same small number of students they're
just started getting their way from like
2012 and on a bit more than they did
before there was a reluctance among the
rest of the people on campus to
challenge them when they stand up and
they shout down whoever it is yeah there
was more willingness on their part to do
so and there was less willingness on the
part of others to condemn them I mean
professors on campuses who are very far
left but again in a more sort of ACLU mo
mold they are afraid to to criticize
these students they're afraid to teach
these students things they might not
agree with I mean that's an important
change and I've talked to a lot of
professors for this book and off the
record who again are progressive people
who are just terrified of their students
I think that is a big problem i I don't
and again I don't want to say that's
every classroom or you know the whole
system is about to come crashing down
but it is a problem if you know even
some subset of professors are not
teaching the law relating to sexual
assault anymore which is something
that's happening because they're afraid
of triggering someone's trauma in the
classroom and you'll have fewer lawyers
who are educated about the nuances of
the laws pertaining to this subject
I mean Harvard just they did this they
they fired a faculty Dean
who Ron Sullivan who is an expert on
criminal justice reform who advised
President Obama or when he was Senator
Obama who has helped free wrongfully
incarcerated people who has represented
accused terrorists and accused murderers
because that's what you do if you
believe in due process but he had joined
Harvey Weinstein's legal team and some
of the 50 student activists said campus
is unsafe for women because you did that
and Harvard listened and they fired the
person I think that's pretty terrible
even if that's even if we're talking
about a handful of incidents rather than
a broad trend I still think that's
pretty bad yeah you're seeing them
actually cave to the demands where
you're saying in the past that was more
likely to be this loud small contingent
possibly just ignored mostly the most
dramatic example I can think of as what
played out at Evergreen College with
Brett Weinstein where you see an entire
group of students swarming the head of
the college and he's basically sitting
there taking it I think they even tell
him to shut up and sit down at one point
and they had them have them like
barricaded in a library they essentially
hold him hostage it's like it's kind of
crazy stuff yeah so what's changed there
is it this administrative apparatus that
is enabling this or is it just the tide
has turned and the power dynamics have
switched somewhat I think the power
dynamics switched somewhat I think for a
couple reasons I mean one of them is if
we're talking specifically about
activism relating to sexual misconduct
on campus the title nine change so title
nine is the statute that forbids
gender-based discrimination in all in
all schools that received federal
funding there was a change to that
statute I mean not technically the
statute remained the same but how it was
interpreted by the Obama administration
in 2011 they broadened what they
considered sexual discrimination to be
kind of all sexual misconduct and they
said the the definition for whether this
would be reasonable or is basically you
know in the eyes of the beholder so
universities got really spooked that if
they didn't very vigorously
police sexual misconduct they could be
losing federal funding so this has a
speech component because again as I was
saying about professors teaching the law
as it relates to sexual assault if you
make someone in your class feel
uncomfortable for a sex or gender-based
reason well now there's this bureaucracy
saying you've possibly violated federal
law and you could put the entire
university at risk for funding so
there's a lot of self censoring there
was a lot of professors who stood up to
this like Laura Kipnis is someone who I
know you've interviewed a reason has
interviewed about this ordeal she went
through when she wrote an essay
criticizing title nine essentially and
her students filed a complaint against
her for having written this essay and
she was investigated again this is just
like throwing academic freedom the First
Amendment the a climate of free
expression on campus all of that going
out the window to comply with this
overly broad interpretation of a statute
I mean there are activists who got that
numeral nine tattooed to their ankles
because it was that important to their
activism so that's an example of
actually an explicit government policy
change having a big impact it took it
took I think maybe like two or three
years for activists to really understand
that we have this tool now for for going
after people for these reasons and that
is the one thing that has actually
changed since I finished the book the
education secretary Betsy DeVos
rescinded that new definition I think
much to her credit so you will have a
sort of less craziness around that
although the people they hired the title
9 coordinators on campus to still kind
of follow those rules they're still
there you know mission creep and
bureaucracies expand and they contract
even when they they get told you don't
have to do this anymore I don't know
yeah and this topic is one of the
cultural hot buttons right now and
people who talk about it and write about
it are often viewed with suspicion and
sometimes rightly so because there's a
whole version of this where it's just
people trying to make college students
look stupid to score points for their
political side I don't
think your book is that I think it's a
sincere attempt like you were saying to
improve the tactics of the left to
succeed in areas that we as libertarians
would want to see them succeed but what
would your advice be to people who are
talking about this and trying to do it
in that smart
more nuanced way without falling into
the more parody version of this
absolutely I think it's so important to
call out the right as well when they are
threatening free speech even I mean even
on college campuses they are there are
all there are Republican legislators
trying to pass bills that are even
sometimes designed as free speech bills
but would actually just make it sort of
hard to protest I mean you could the
students can protest the speaker's they
should protest the speakers they just
can't shut them down or exercise
violence against them but there is
speech relating to sort of
pro-palestinian speech on campuses is
often something that conservatives have
have said well we're gonna kind of crush
this so so I try to I try to defend you
know a professor's right to not write a
letter of recommendation for someone who
wants to study abroad in Israel that was
something that happened at Michigan
that's a free speech issue there are a
freedom of association issue so I think
it's just so important to make sure
we're calling out both sides
I don't think conservatives I don't
think Trump is especially a big defender
of freedom of speech even if he maybe
says things I occasionally agree with
about speech on campuses particularly so
it's just I mean he wants to expand
libel laws he said that so I think some
of the criticisms coming at people who
fixate on campus free speech issues is
sometimes there are people who make it
look like that's the only thing going on
and you know if we only if we got rid of
political correctness everything would
be great our only mission is to is to
stop this sort of campus social justice
warrior so I'm here saying campus social
justice for years occasionally doing
some bad stuff we should be aware of
this is not made up this is a real story
but there are a lot
other stories - about speech and about
other things where we're the people of
authority are our people who are hurting
the free speech rights of the left as
well I mean this is my plea to activist
that if we empower authorities to take -
to quash free speech I mean whose speech
are they coming for first
I mean it's there's gonna be anti-war
speech is gonna be offensive or
triggering for for members of the
military community auntie Polly criminal
justice reform is gonna be speech that
you know impugns are cops yeah I've
always seen the blue lives matter meme
so that's one example exactly that's
exactly things like that so I'm just
you're saying we got to defend broad
sort of free speech classical liberal
principles and we have to defend them
from the left but certainly from the
right as well so if you're arguing that
intersectionality is ultimately
self-defeating and empowering people
like on the alt right and to some degree
Trump himself what would a course
correction look like in your mind like
what I guess is kind of a best-case
scenario to move beyond this I would
like to see some of the performative
intersectionality dialed down
particularly on social media like there
have been efforts lately undertaken by
sort of far left young adult book
reviewers to destroy every young adult
novel that has something they perceive
as problematic in it even if it's not
really problematic when you look at it
like I mean there was a book written you
know this is a fantasy book about kind
of the anastasia myth in russia but like
with magic and vampires and things like
that
yeah but the criticism was and it's an
it's an asian author but their slavery
in the book and the criticism was well
slavery something that happened in the
american south how dare you culturally
appropriating this story of slavery of
course slavery is something that has
happened everywhere including in Russia
so it's ridiculous but they got they got
this author to cancel this book despite
having gotten a five hundred thousand
dollar advance now she's publishing it
but she's changed all the problematic
parts something like that anyway this
kind of just purely performative burned
the which canceled culture that is anime
by and by intersectionality and a sort
of militant paying attention to small
grievances is having negative effects on
our culture I think depending on the
firm I mean your companies are gonna
take less sort of creative or culturally
interesting moves if you have to satisfy
these just very unreasonable woek
demands so I'm trying to explain why I
do think that's bad and self-defeating
and it just and then it it drives the
the right I mean this animates so much
criticism of progressivism when some of
progressivism is good and I would agree
with it
so I would like them to dial back the
the the kind of all the going overboard
you do not not necessarily because of
the theory but the theory has has helped
push them in that direction what do you
hope that libertarian-leaning people
learn from reading this book I think the
most important point I want to hammer
home is that you know there's this idea
that professors are sort of like
brainwashing students or something and
in the the Academy is evil because like
education itself is evil or something
like that
I don't quite think that's what's been
going on here I think most of these
students who have learned tactics we
don't like are actually learning them
from each other I think the faculty
could be our allies in this kind of
struggle I mean they when they talk to
me they're very concerned about these
things because they are the ones we're
gonna get in trouble
so I would like to see a dialing down of
the rhetoric on how like professors are
brainwashing their students or something
like that
because I don't think that's quite the
case and and many professors even though
we don't agree with them on everything
do represent or do have respect for
individual liberty and in some cases and
might have respect for individual
liberty even in even more cases if we if
we come to their defense and and and
we're their protectors here rather than
we want to dismiss them because we think
this is their fault so if it's not their
fault where is it coming from because
there is the theory that this is all you
know cultural Marxism being taught by
the professor's so is it something more
structural is it back to that
administrative bloat the administrative
bloat is certainly part of the story but
I think the students are really just
learning it from each other
because of the way social media is and
they're in facebook groups and the
they can learn you know activists at one
college can see what activists at
another have done you know they're
sharing like you know quotes from from
famous sort of activist figures of your
they're seeing what worked at other
colleges there is a there is there are
some academic disciplines where this is
taught a little bit and it's really more
activism being taught than anything
approaching scholarship yeah
that's a kind of small part of academia
so if they're learning from each other
then this is in a way technological
because it seems like you're saying it's
social media essentially that is at
least accelerating well technology makes
it very easy for people across wide
Geographic distances to cluster around
causes or ideas yeah I mean the
alt-right
and this is not technology this is a
good thing as well the you know
technology allows us to connect to
like-minded people and identify them and
interact with them and it's broadly a
good thing but something like the
alt-right would not have been possible
before this because you know you can
have a couple a small number of racist
people spread out all over the country
and they would think they were alone and
they would never express their views out
of fear of social stigma now they can
find each other and they can create kind
of enclaves for them to to express their
ideas well if the technological change
was part of the problem or at least an
accelerant to the problem can it be part
of the solution is there any way to
leverage technology to course-correct in
some way yeah it's a difficult question
and it's one that technology companies
are really grappling with them with
themselves right now because they're
trying to decide do how much policing of
this content should we do if we do it do
we look hypocritical when we don't get
rid of all problematic content I mean
it's impossible to do these are giant
networks and who have made you know sort
of implicit free speech you know we're
platforms so this is kind of like the
public square this is something Facebook
has said no you know this is a place
where we're we're not gonna police you
for what you say but it turns any the
public in the truly in the public square
you can say really awful vile things and
that's okay
that's constitutional that's protected
under the
first amendment are we really giving
that much license now they're saying
well wait a minute maybe we didn't
intend to do that and I actually tend to
think heavy-handed attempts to ban the
bad people just will not work or make
the platform look look very hypocritical
and actually just make people angry or
even dried this under further
underground
but the companies can do what they want
you know I'm not one of those
libertarians who has suddenly decided
not libertarian or anti anti social
justice warrior people who has suddenly
decided that government intervention
into into this sector is not only
justified but absolutely necessary my
principles were ready to collapse that
easily which is something unfortunately
I see many other people who talk about
these issues have suddenly decided
Facebook should be broken up by the
government because it was mean to some
conservative once which is which is
pretty frustrating how was your
experience writing and researching this
book affected your view of American
politics and where things might be
headed next that's interesting certainly
over the course of time that I was
writing this book politics became even
more polarized part of the issue is that
Trump C's has made the media his enemy
his is the rival team and the media
plays into it to some degree it partly
because they're just doing their job of
criticizing Trump others take it a bit
farther than that but they are the
opposition team so they're not like like
the the mediators in it in a dispute
between Democrats and Republicans that
used to be their old position
Republicans complain they were too much
too affiliated with Democrats but now
it's like Trump versus media yeah so
everything that happens and because
Trump owns the new cycle and there's
nothing that can happen that does not
relate to Trump in some way there's this
need to fit it into that lens of Trump
versus media so like went like when the
Covington the kids on the Lincoln
Memorial that's something I wrote a lot
about saying that the media had gotten
the story wrong but I'm not saying that
because I'm like defending Trump at but
that's they tried to you know people
seeing me writing about it or like well
are you on the
side of the media or are you saying
Trump is good and right I was saying
neither of those things but it's so it's
it's hard it's become harder yeah to be
a person who's talking about issues who
sometimes thinks the media is right
sometimes thinks the characterization is
correct
sometimes defense try and just be not in
either of those sides there's the
constant which tribe are you in it
doesn't make sense to people anymore
yeah that you wouldn't be in one or the
other yeah how do you get around that
how do you get out of that situation
you can't get out of the situation the
hard part is making sure then you don't
put one foot in one camp because you're
being pushed to get into one of those
Bryce that's and I as a libertarian I
don't want to be in either of those
camps I don't think libertarians should
want to be in either of those camps we
should you know maintain our ability to
to make situational alliances but to
call out you know big government and
violations of our values wherever they
occur but the the nature of the
political conversation is really trying
to push you in one direction so it's I'm
you're just standing on a platform in
the sea trying not to fall into the
waves or something yeah and do you think
that sea is just going to continue to
get choppier or is there any hope of you
know calmer waters initially I don't see
any reason why there would be calmer
waters at least in the immediate future
if Trump were to lose the election maybe
we'll have a different paradigm it could
very well be that this continues because
you'll replace Trump with something else
and it will be the exact same dynamic or
we won't replace him at all
who knows certainly the kind of call out
cancel II stuff I talk about is going to
get worse as more I think activists type
people move from campus into the
workplace
again it's not most young people but it
only needs one at a major media
institution or social media company who
is changing the culture from within by
saying that if you're doing this or
you're doing that it violates harassment
law it's a form of your traumatizing me
you're making the workplace unsafe this
is why Kevin Williamson can't work at
the Atlantic because he holds views that
made some people on staff it wasn't
literally that they disagree with his
views this is
writer for The Atlantic briefly for a
week it was his views made certain
employees feel unsafe so that kind of
again that's different than disagreement
that's taking it to a level that we're
going to see happen in in firm or in
situation after situation that's going
to really change America over the next
ten years okay we've got choppier waters
ahead hold on to your flotation devices
Robbie thank you very much for talking
to us my pleasure